kulinarische Erzeugnisse aus Italien
genießen weltweit nahezu uneingeschränkt
Wertschätzung von den Erzeugnissen die
in italienischen Wahllokalen
gelegentlich zusammengemischt werden
kann dies nicht unbedingt behauptet
werden zum Schrecken von pro-europäern
liberalen und linken kommt in Rom eine
rechtspopulistisch bis rechtsradikale
Koalition an die Macht die allerdings
durch eine demokratische Wahl
legitimiert ist was wollten die
italienischen Wählerinnen und Wähler
also kundtun
Rechtsruck in Italien was wird aus
Europa jetzt in der Phönix Runde
herzlich Willkommen bei uns meine Gäste
Tonia mastubborn ist bei uns
italienische Journalistin sie sind
Korrespondentin der Tageszeitung la
Republica hier in Berlin und sie haben
den
Wahlabend in ihrer italienischen Heimat
verbracht waren auch auf den letzten
wahlkundgebungen unter anderem auch der
Wahlsieger Elmar Bruck ist CDU-Politiker
war fast 40 Jahre Mitglied im
Europäischen Parlament und auch dort
lange Jahre Vorsitzender des Auswärtigen
Ausschusses Frank ahrmeier Schweizer
Journalist lebt hier in Berlin und sie
schreiben unter anderem für das Magazin
Cicero das gehört auch dazu siehe vor
einigen Jahren mitgegründet haben Ralf
Sina war sechs Jahre lang Leiter des ARD
hörfunkstudios in Brüssel Frau
masturboni
erklären Sie uns das politische Gemüt
der in Italien der Italienerinnen und
Italiener wir manche glauben ja zu
wissen wie das ist es ist ja eine in
Italien so wer gestern noch klein war
ist jetzt groß und wer gestern groß war
jetzt klein da gibt es ja einige
Beispiele bei den Parteien lieben ihre
Landsleute das Achterbahn fahren
gute Frage ja ich frage mich auch immer
warum sie sich alle drei vier Jahre in
einem messianische Figur
übergeben weil sie weil sie sehr sehr
schnell müde werden aber wenn man das
genau betrachtet ich meine Georgia
Meloni hat 26% der Stimmen kassiert das
ist weniger eben als die früheren
messianischen Figuren kassiert hatten
spezifische Matteo reinziehe oder auch
Matthäus Salvini
berusconi früher das waren ganz andere
Zahlen das war über 30 Prozent das heißt
keiner hat sie hat eindeutig die Wahlen
gewonnen weil die anderen Parteien sehr
schwach waren und weil auch das mit den
Linksbündnis sich eben nicht dazu
geeinigt hat ein Bündnis also als als
Koalition die Wahlen anzugehen aber ich
denke mal erstens sie weiß selber noch
nicht was sie mit diesem Ergebnis macht
das werden wir ja vielleicht auch dann
besprechen und zweitens wie gesagt also
es ist ein eindeutig Ergebnis für Sie
und jetzt werden wir mal gucken das ist
alles noch sehr sehr undeutlich was da
passieren wird
für die Anhänger der europäischen Idee
immer pro war das vielleicht kein guter
Abend ich sag's mal ganz oder frag mal
ganz zugespitzt hat die Wahl in Italien
das Zeug die EU in ihrer bisherigen Form
zu springen
das könnte sein aber ich glaube es nicht
denn
ich verfolge nun auch seit mehr in
Jahrzehnten italienische Politik
alles in den politischen System dort
kann man sagen es wird nicht zu heiß
gegessen wie es gekocht wird ich hoffe
dass das diesmal wieder der Fall ist das
weiß ich allerdings nicht ich kenne fast
alle handeln da aber Frau Meloni kenne
ich nicht persönlich und kann das
schlecht beurteilen aber sie ist der
eindeutige Sieger den derjenigen der
dieser möglichen Koalition als derjenige
ist wenn er nicht am meisten Sorgen in
Europa habe wäre es alvini der fanatisch
ist oder
explodiert Salvini ist da eigentliche
wahlverlehrer der noch 8,8% gekriegt
seine vernichtende Niederlage für sowie
die in diesem Konzert und deswegen wird
er nicht die entsprechend
Einflussmöglichkeiten haben wie sich der
alte Berlusconi Tab benimmt was kein
Mensch aber da ist zumindest
die Gene ein Stück in europäisch
ausgerichtet
so dass das dort hinein geht und wir
müssen sehen dass beispielsweise Meloni
wirtschaftlich der in Brüssel auch in
Brüssel eine große Rolle spielte hoch
anerkannt jetzt Frau Meloni
wahrscheinlich ja im Begleitung Emma
Burg hat es angesprochen von Matthäus
Salvini der als Innenminister in Brüssel
bekannt ist und von einem Berlusconi der
Herrn Putin in einer Weise hofiert das
einem schon schlecht werden kann das
heißt also zwei Putin Fans in
Anführungszeichen in dieser Troika mit
Frau Meloni die selber keine ist aber
zwei an der Seite das ist für Brüssel
ein Problem und es ist vor allen Dingen
deshalb glaube ich ein Problem weil das
ganze sich in einem Koordinatensystem
zusammen abspielt mit Ungarn mit Polen
zur pisspartei hat ja Frau Meloni ganz
gute Drähte mit einem
Frankreich das Gott sei Dank noch gerade
davon gekommen ist aber wo ja Frau
Lippen auch keine ganz unwichtige Rolle
spielt mit einem Schweden wo die
Schweden Demokraten keine ganz unwicht
Geräusche spielen das heißt in einem
Koordinatensystem in der EU wo die
rechtsnationalistische Flanke deutlich
stärker wird das heißt wir werden in
Zukunft vor den Abstimmungen der EU mit
Italien in einem großen Land
mit deutlichen Schwierigkeiten rechnen
müssen und mit Allianzen gerade vor
Viktor Orban und das ist in der Tat für
die EU-Kommission für die EU insgesamt
eine sehr Herausforderung gehört ja zur
Geschichte der EU seit langer Zeit das
gegenseitige Missvergnügen braucht die
Europäische Union denn spätestens jetzt
nach diesen Erfahrungen der Wahlen
dieses Jahres eine Reform an Haupt- und
Gliedern das wird ja nicht machbar sein
weil genau die Kräfte die jetzt stark
werden in der EU werden dafür nicht
bereit sein und ich glaube auch dass die
die deutsche Idee von
Europa sich nicht durchsetzen wird es
wird ein Europa der Nationen bleiben und
ich muss schon sagen dass mich ein
bisschen gestört hat dass man von
Brüssel aus sofort auf diese Wahl
reagiert hat das ist die Wahl Italiens
und wir sind alle wahnsinnig aufgeregt
weil der Begriff der Name Mussolini in
diesem Zusammenhang plötzlich eine Rolle
spielt das ist natürlich fürchterliche
Begriff in Italien als würde in
Deutschland Präsident Name Hitler eine
Rolle spielen in Wahlen nicht die die
beziehen sich ja so aber das hat keine
Bedeutung mehr wir sind zu aufgeregt
einerseits über Italien und ein bisschen
zu wenig aber sie haben es angesprochene
Sina über das was in Europa passiert wir
haben in Europa
rechtspopulistische Kräfte wie auch
immer sie sich zusammensetzen ob mit der
mit der Linie Mussolini oder mit der
Vulgarität eines Salvini das ist ja
nicht ganz so wichtig wichtig ist dass
diese rechtspopulistischen Kräfte in
Europa eine Rolle spielen und zunehmend
eine Macht sind und wir uns nämlich
fragen müssen warum das so
herausgekommen ist und da möchte ich zum
Schluss meines meine Aussage hier mal
sagen wir müssen uns nicht fragen was
die Rechten gemacht haben sondern mal
fragen was links der Mitte passiert ist
dass eine Klientel die eigentlich zu
denen gehört die ganz normalen einfachen
Bürgerinnen und Bürger in Europa in
Schweden in in Frankreich wahrscheinlich
demnachs auch mal dass die hingehen und
rechtspopulistisch wählen eine Antwort
gibt es in der Schweiz ist die stärkste
Partei die rechtspopulistische SVPS die
stärkste Partei in der Schweiz sie wird
gewählt von den Arbeitnehmern nicht die
Sozialdemokraten und von den Grünen
wollen wir gar nicht reden das ist die
Arbeitnehmer weil wählen heute
populistisch rechts
Schweden waren die Sozialdemokraten zwar
die stärkste Partei aber hat ihn dann
nichts genutzt oder wird ihn jetzt bei
der Koalitionsbildung die sitzen ich
würde das was sie jetzt gerade
angesprochen haben ist ja das Thema der
Sendung unter anderem rauszukriegen wie
ist es soweit mit Europa gekommen wir
sollten Frau masturbone aber vielleicht
erstmal kurz das Wahlergebnis in seine
Bestandteile zerlegen denn es sind ja
hier verschiedene Stichworte schon
gefallen postfaschismus Mussolini ganz
kurz wer ist Georgia Melone die da jetzt
vom Fernsehen zwar kennen ihr kennt nur
kurze Rede Ausschnitte von ihr was ist
das für eine Bewegung die fratelli
Italia die Brüder Italiens wie muss man
die einschätzen da wird immer das
Adjektiv postfaschistisch genannt das
auch ein bisschen seltsam klingt was ist
das für eine Bewegung was ist das für
eine Frau die jetzt an der in Zukunft an
der Regierung Spitze stehen wird also
erstens ich würde nicht sagen dass hier
rechtspopulistisch ist ich würde sagen
sie ist rechts nat realistisch es gibt
da eine neue Rechte in Europa die sich
auch zum Beispiel in Spanien durch VOX
ausdrückt und so weiter die ist
chauvinistisch die ist eben
nationalistisch und das ist etwas anders
sie greift nicht Themen auf wie Salvini
eben ob vulgäre Weise auf laute Weise
und und nutzt sie aus um um Wählerschaft
zu sie hat wirklich ein Programm sie hat
ein sie hat zumindest im Kopf die Idee
dass zum Beispiel einige Befugnisse an
Italien zurückgegeben werden müssen und
da ist ein sehr sehr gefährliches
Szenario kommt da ein Spiel weil
natürlich sie hat eben angedeutet in der
europäischen Gruppe in der
parlamentsgruppe der ECR wo sie ja auch
Präsidentin ist und wo sie ein ganz ganz
schnellen wirklich Aufstieg erlebt hat
ein aufhaltsam um brech zu zitieren da
sitzt ja zusammen schon mit den
Demokraten mit den mit den Dänen mit den
mit peace und ich glaube peace wird
wirklich genau die polnische
Regierungspartei und ich glaube das ist
das gefährlichste getanen Meloni nicht
so sehr ich würde mich nicht so sehr
Sorgen machen um die üblichen Themen
immer zitiert werden Migration natürlich
auch ihre Parolen ihr Vokabular also ich
würde das nicht postfaschistisch ich
würde das neu Neo verschützisch nennen
weil wenn man spricht von genauso wie
AFD in Deutschland oder wie andere
rechtsradikale Parteien von einer
ethnischen von einem ethnischen
Austausch da ging ja hier natürlich
gehen alle Lichter an und und man man
setzt ganz klar rote Linien in
Deutschland in Italien sie so oft diese
oft diese Wort aufs gefallen sie hat es
benutzt und Saline das auch benutzt
faschistisch postfaschistisch
niederfaschistische taucht ja immer der
Name Benito Mussolini aus der Ängste
Verbündete von Adolf Hitler er hat nicht
ganz so schlimm gewütet in Italien wie
Hitler in Deutschland und dann vor allen
Dingen während des Krieges er trotzdem
als Diktator eine Blutspur durch Italien
gezogen
hat Juden deportiert und die Frage haben
die Italiener aus der Geschichte nicht
gelernt oder haben sie anders als in
Deutschland Geschichte nicht so richtig
aufgearbeitet das ist eine sehr gute
Frage natürlich und die eine
grundsätzliche Frage die ich glaube die
Termine am viel weniger die Geschichte
aufgearbeitet als die Deutschen das auf
jeden Fall zumindest in den letzten
Jahrzehnten die Deutschen
die Italiener haben sich sehr oft
verstanden auch als ein Land das ab 1943
zumindest eine sehr starke sehr starken
Widerstand hatte
eins der
bekanntesten widerstandslieder der Welt
ist ja immer noch bella ciao ich glaube
gestern hat liberation oder nee heute
morgen hat die tats irgendwie die
Tageszeitung in Deutschland hat bella
ciao zitiert ich glaube in diesem
Verständnis haben sie oft unter dem
Teppich gekehrt wie faschistisch sie
waren 20 Jahre lang nicht 13 Jahre lang
20 Jahre lang und genau im hundertsten
Jahr nach dem Einmarsch in Rom der
Faschisten ist eben eine eine eine
sozusagen jemand an die Macht gekommen
der aus dieser Tradition kommt Giorgia
Mini war schon mit 15
militant also sie war der
postfaschistischen
italiano
tätig aktiv
sie hat dann aber das ist interessant
sie wurde als sehr junges und sehr
talentiertes
Frau wurde sie in kopiert in der Partei
von
von der francofino war ja der Mann der
gesagt hat der Faschismus ist das
absolute Böse denn nach Israel gereistet
ist und der hat das in Israel glaube ich
auch gesagt diese
national ist eben die Partei die es auch
also die Meloni zum Erfolg sie war die
jüngste Ministerin der Geschichte unter
der Regierung von Berlusconi und und
alle seine nationale sie war ein junges
Talent anerkannt von dieser
postfaschistischen Partei wirklich im
Sinne von Post aber danach hat sie ja
ihre Partei in der Logik gegründet sie
wolle wieder rechter sein als diese
Partei und damals war es auch eine zwei
prozentpartei und jetzt ist es eine 26%
jetzt hat
Firma Brook eine Frau die zumindest in
der Öffentlichkeit stark wirkt
vielleicht auch stark ist ja zwei
Schwächlinge an ihrer Seite Matteo
Salvini und Silvio Berlusconi die Weite
wahrscheinlich ihre politische Zukunft
hinter sich haben ich sage das durchaus
etwas lakonisch gemeint
spielt überhaupt noch eine Rolle oder
wie könnte man sich diese
Konstellationen in Italien sie
verlusconi und die fahrzeugitalia ist ja
eine Schwesterpartei auch der Union wie
kann man sich diese Konstellation
vorstellen
Melone wird darauf angewiesen sein wenn
man sich da mal die Zahlen zusammenhängt
was die anderen Parteien bekommen halten
wenn die Partie der demokratiko eine
Koalition der Mitte Linkspartei zustande
bekommen hätten ja aber die Führung sind
Christdemokraten in ricoletta kenne ich
noch als Vorsitzende europäischen
Christen jungen Christopher geraten ist
ein brodimann
und
Renzi ist auch ein alter Christdemokrat
da ist übrigens die Schwäche für die
vielleicht noch reden können dass wir
als eVB nicht in der Lage waren eine
vernünftige Mitarbeit aufzubauen das
Personal ist da das hat sich nur
verteilt auf verschiedene Parteien ich
glaube
dass die
Trickser wie boluskune eine Rolle spielt
das Draghi vorzeitig gestürzt ist war
die Arbeit von Berlusconi durch eine
Mittagessen Einladung seine Villa was
alvini und
Meloni überzeugt hat dass wenn ich jetzt
schon das Misstrauensvotum macht obwohl
zwei der Parteien nämlich Mitglied der
Koalition war von Dagi das heißt das
hingedeichselt das Neuwahlen stattfinden
war berlusconig die Frage ist ja welchen
Spielraum hat Melone eigentlich welchen
politischen Spielraum ist jetzt viel
angekündigt das ist in allen
demokratischen Staaten der Welt so im
Wahlkampf jetzt muss sie liefern aber
sie ist ja möglicherweise auch in ihren
in ihrem Aktionsradius beschränkt sie
muss auch viel Rücksicht nehmen auf der
italienischen wie auf der europäischen
Ebene wird sie da ziemlich bald von den
europäischen Realitäten eingeholt also
die EU-Kommission hat ja heute etwas
freigegeben nämlich die zweite Tranche
dieses fast 200 Milliarden Pakets an
Italien ich glaube bei 26 Milliarden ist
natürlich ein Signal erstmal an Frau
Meloni und die Herren die sie ja
wahrscheinlich begleiten dass der
draghikus der Reformen in Italien
fortgesetzt werden soll und dass die
Auszahlung daran hängt und wenn sie nach
dem Spielraum Fragen der wird sicherlich
hoffentlich dadurch etwas begrenzt dass
die EU-Kommission und die EU insgesamt
genau hinguckt was passiert da jetzt und
zahlen wir weiter oder zahlen wir nicht
bei Ungarn ist man ja immerhin auf dem
Weg jetzt finanzielle Sanktionen zu
erwägen zumindest und Polen und das
blüht sicherlich auch Frau Meloni was
Salvini angeht glaube ich hat der vor
wieder Innenminister zu werden und
wieder in Brüssel aufzulaufen und seine
Idee der Seeblockade vorzutragen und die
Idee wieder italienische Häfen zu
sperren und die die
den italienischen Geheimdienst
einzusetzen gegen Hilfsorganisationen
wie save the child und andere die
Flüchtlinge versuchen zu retten also da
erwartet die Uhr einiges aber insgesamt
zu sehr ich auch entsetzt bin dass an
diesem jahresdach dem hunderten von
mussolinismarsch auf Rom eine solche
Frau die waren gewonnen hat frage ich
mich immer sind es nicht im Grunde um
Krisensymptome einer EU diese Tatsache
dieses was er mal was sie gerade
angesprochen haben dieses starken
Rechtsrucks in Schweden
sozialdemokratisches Vorzeigeland und
und und und müssen wir uns als Europäer
nicht auch fragen was machen wir falsch
das solche Figuren
plötzlich an die Macht kommen und da
fände ich es für die EU auch wichtig
nicht nur jetzt sozusagen immer wieder
zu sagen eine postfaschistin was ja
richtig ist sie hat sich nie davon
distanziert und all diese
Widerlichkeiten aber zu fragen was
machen wir falsch das plötzlich die
Marine Le Pens dieser Welt
und Frau Melonen ist und Schweden
Demokraten so stark werden was läuft
falsch das ist ja die Frage man könnte
sie auch anders formulieren herr Maier
wo sind denn eigentlich die anderen die
Parteien der Mitte die für die
europäische Idee stehen die die
europäische Idee hochhalten diese die EU
prägen wollen die sie in einen mit
Player Global Player neben China USA
Russland wahrscheinlich nicht mehr
stellen wollen wo sind die
Sozialdemokraten die Liberalen die
Parteien der Mitte die Christdemokraten
die offensichtlich ja nicht in der Lage
sind eine solche Entwicklung in Europa
zu verhindern also ist ja eine
semantische Frage ob das
Rechtspopulisten sind oder nicht oder
nationaler Rechtspopulisten sind sehr
nationalistisch also das ist einfach
eine auch das faschistoide spielt bei
den Rechtspopulisten riesenrolle warum
werden die gewählt die werden nicht
gewählt weil sie sagen wir sind also wie
kann man aus der Tradition des
Faschismus oder Pflicht das ist es nicht
das was wir diskutieren ist es nicht für
den Wähler für den Wähler ist es dass
die davon reden von Dingen reden von
denen die anderen nicht reden ich sage
es jetzt mal ganz einfach benennen
die benennen Dinge die schaut zum
Beispiel Vaterland das sagt sie ja
Nation sagt Sie Christin sagt sie alles
Dinge wo Leute sagen ja eigentlich warum
nicht also ich bitte Sie das sind wir
sagte sie entsetzlich dass er kein
Programm was ist dieses dacato man nennt
das war seine
Vortrag den sie da hält und das Staunen
wir uns am Donnerwetter intellektuell
ist das nirgends aber offenbar benennt
es etwas und wir müssen aufpassen wir
wir gehören nämlich genau zu denen die
mit den ganz einfachen Leuten nichts
mehr zu tun haben wir sind eine Elite
das ist in Ordnung Gesellschaften
brauchen Eliten aber
wir wollen das gar nicht mehr hören
diese ganz Heimat Heimat in Deutschland
darf man jetzt wieder ich habe es
beobachtet wie schwierig es war Heimat
die Leute wollen Heimat sie wollen sie
zusammen zu Hause fühlen und diese Dinge
die wir nicht benennen übrigens auch in
der Migrationspolitik wie verdrängen wir
so sehr dass wir inzwischen das Gefühl
haben eigentlich kein richtiges Problem
mehr aber das ist ein Riesenproblem für
Menschen die vielleicht gar nicht
betroffen sind aber das sehen Sie ich
bin doch bei mir zu Hause ich bin doch
da und die sagen das die die
Rechtspopulisten das Wesen der ist die
wollen kein Problem lösen die wollen das
Problem bewirtschaften denn wenn sie es
lösen würden wären sie überflüssigen und
aus dem abzuleiten dass es an den
Mitteparteien an diese Christdemokraten
den Begriff würde und dann schaue was
sie daraus gemacht haben nicht oder die
Sozialdemokraten ich war Sozialdemokrat
User alles
das Gewerkschafter das meine Vita mit
denen habe ich nichts mehr zu tun wer da
rutschendet und sich um also um die
Aufhebung der Damentoiletten können wir
damit Transsexuelle kein Problem haben
in diesen ganzen Kindergarten kann ich
nicht mehr sehen und Entschuldigung nur
noch das die haben nichts mehr zu tun
mit den ganzen normalen einfachen Leute
die morgens um Siegen ihre Kinder in die
Schule bringen und arbeiten gehen und
das Problem
identifiziert wird die EU wird damit
identifiziert und das bringt sozusagen
diese Kräfte der Furcht sag ich noch ein
Wort wenn wenn Freund von mir hat mir
heute noch erzählt er hat sich mit einer
polnischen
Beckers Frau unterhalten und die hat
gesagt mensch ihr in Brüssel ihr EU
Leute ihr attackiert die Familie und hat
dann als Beispiel genannt gesagt
plötzlich wird Vater und Mutter ist
nicht mehr gefragt sondern man soll
sagen
Nummer 1 und älter 2 das hat gar nichts
mit Brüssel zu tun das war ein
Vorschlages Europarates aber das hat
jetzt die Bäckerin diese feine
Unterschied hat sie nicht gemacht aber
sie hat assoziiert der Angriff auf das
klassische Familiensystem was in Polen
eine große Rolle spielt was jetzt ja
auch von Frau Meloni wieder beschworen
hat und so weiter und in anderen Ländern
auch das wird sozusagen
attackiert und Brüssel gilt als Schiffe
als Symbol dieser Attacke und das halte
ich für ein ganz großes Problem da ist
also erstens in Italien ist es kein
semantischer Unterschied
Rechtspopulismus oder
rechtsnationalismus weil die leger von
Matthäus Salvini war überhaupt nicht
nationalistisch die Liga von Matthäus
Salvini ist gegründet worden als eine
sogar eine Autonomie eine Partei die
sollte die Autonomie des Nordens
erreichen und es war eine
föderalistische Partei er hat sich dann
am Ende hat er das Lega Nord weggenommen
und hat versucht den Süden zu erobern
aber es ist ein Riesenunterschied in
Italien zwischen dem Populismus von
Salvini und dem rechtsnationalismus von
melonias muss einfach gesagt werden weil
das ist was ganz Neues in Italien das so
eine Partei so ein riesen Erfolg hat und
darüber muss man sich eben fragen was
ich dazu sagen ich denke die Analyse die
technischen Wahl riskiert bei diesen
Themen etwas
erstens hat über die Hälfte der
Italiener haben für nicht rechte Partei
gewählt also wenn man die die absoluten
Zahlen nimmt dann haben die meisten
Italiener erstens die Wahlbeteiligung
war die niedrigste der Geschichte und
das ist schon mal ein Fakt und viele
junge Leute sind nicht wählen gegangen
und ich sage jetzt auch in einer Minute
warum glaube ich dass viele junge Leute
nicht wählen gegangen sind
zweitens die Hälfte mehr als die Hälfte
Italiener haben nicht für diese Parteien
gewählt nur diese die eben die
Sozialdemokraten und die fünf Sterne
Bewegungen haben sich nicht dazu
aufraffen können ein Bündnis zu zu
machen Kalender Orient sie sind zwei
Idiot
Figuren die die es auch nicht geschafft
haben die sind alle für sich selbst
gerannt und deswegen haben sie die
Wahlen verloren es gibt einfach auch ein
wahltaktisches auf der in der Mitte auf
der linken Seite in Italien nicht was
auf der rechten passiert nämlich eine
Bündnis zu schließen denn das Wahlgesetz
würde ja Bündnisse natürlich wenn man
gemeinsame Kandidaten hat
da muss man einfach Bündnisse machen da
muss man machen
diesmal nicht genau Prinzi und letter
geht gar nicht und ich wollte auch daran
erinnern dass nicht nur ich meine die
fünf Sterne Bewegung wir vergessen ein
bisschen die fünf Sterne Bewegung ist
der zweite große Sieger dieser Wahl das
muss man sagen und alle hatten sie für
tot erklärt
die fünf stellenbewegung hat trotz allem
noch ein sehr gute Prozentzahl kassiert
und vor allen Dingen sie ist erste
Partei in fast den ganzen Süden warum
weil die fünf Sterne Bewegung wird
identifiziert jetzt mit einer linken
Partei weil sie ein ein einziges großes
linkes Thema hat und das ist das
Bürgergeld und es ist nun mal so und
darauf komme ich auf den jungen Leute
die jungen Leute in Italien die haben
Einkommen das ist völlig lächerlich und
das ist entwürdigend was die verdienen
und deswegen gehen sie massenweise nach
Deutschland gehen sie massenweise nach
Frankreich nach England nach Amerika und
im Süden ist es insbesondere so wenn ein
junger Mensch gerade sein keine Ahnung
sein Magister macht oder seinen Abfluss
macht und dann
wird er eingestellt in einer Firma er
kriegt so wenig Geld dass er oft
überlegt und sagt naja ich kriege
wahrscheinlich mehr Geld wenn ich habe
das Bürgergeld kassiere dann mache ich
gar nichts oder ich arbeite schwarz und
die Linke
Möglichkeiten vielleicht nicht zufällig
und letzter Satz und deswegen denke ich
passiert Demokratie Gottes völlig
verpasst ein großes Thema für sich zu
stellen ich hätte suggeriert den
Mindestlohn es ist das einzige Land in
Europa das noch kein Mindestlohn hat
warum weil die ist die Partie und
Demokratie sind nicht im Stande sich von
den Gewerkschaften zu befreien und die
Gewerkschaften wollen natürlich nicht
ihre machts verlieren da am Tisch zu
sitzen und die Verträge zu tun Meloni
viel versprochen vor allen Dingen
ausgabenorientiertes in Italien
elmarbrook sie bekommt Geld aus Brüssel
wenn sie Reformen durchführt jetzt muss
man sehen inwieweit die tatsächlich
durchgeführt werden
könnte in Italien ein zweites
Griechenland entstehen dass durch
Ausgaben Politik durch massive
Schuldenaufnahme ständige Verletzung der
maastrichtkriterien also wie viel
Schulden ein Land aufnehmen darf könnte
da damit auch
eine große Gefahr nicht nur für die
Europäische Union sondern auch für die
europäische Währung entstehen lasse mich
Einsatz zu der Folien Diskussion sagen
denn wir müssen Fischeln es gibt links
Populisten das sind die fünf Sterne und
Rechtspopulisten Populisten sind weder
rechts noch links sie sind Populisten
kaschitzki gewinnt seine Wahl mit
Sozialprogrammen nicht mit rechten
Parolen und so ist das auch in früheren
populistischen faschistischen Regierung
gefallen das mitunter rechts und links
ist falsch fit so Mitglieder Sozialisten
in Slowakei ist ein übler Populist ein
Anti europäischer Populist der wird weil
er bei den Sozialdemokraten ist leider
nicht diskutiert aber ist auch mal voll
hinzuschauen und bei den Schweden
Demokraten wir haben in Dänemark in
Schweden und in Finnland bei
Minderheiten zur Regierung immer solche
Parteien gab die Stützen oder auch
moskauhörige Kommunisten die ja die
andere Seite gestützt haben also das ist
Tradition und ist nicht immer so
dramatisch ist im Augenblick dargestellt
wird
sozialpopulisten dann
und nein das ist der ist auch ein sozial
deswegen ist es aber jetzt ist will ich
das nicht weiter fortsetzen sondern ihre
Frage beantworten
theoretisch ist das könnte das möglich
sein dass das wie in Griechenland geht
aber ich glaube es nicht
einmal gibt es faustform von Meloni aus
den letzten Tagen die bei dem Eindruck
habe dass sie das Problem verstanden hat
sie ist Salvini ist derjenige der viel
Geld ausgeben will nicht Meloni und das
wir können nur in Schulden machen sie
hatte sie weiß dass sie dann sofort die
Basis ihres Erfolges zerstört wenn das
zusammenbricht und es gibt ein zweiter
Punkt dieser Frage der italienische
Präsident hat sehr viel mehr Macht als
der deutsche und der wird nicht jeden
Wirtschafts- und Finanzminister
Genehmigung und sagen dann kriegst du
meine Ernennung nicht du ich möchte da
eine Person haben dass man eben bei
Außenministerin wird das bezahlt deine
Bewegung ja und das und ich nehme an
dass der Präsident das wieder machen
wird deswegen wird er auch darauf achten
dass da ein nicht an das dann eher
europäischer vernünftiger Mensch ins
Finanzamt ist eine Konfrontation mit
Brüssel da auch unvermeidbar ja Anekdote
erzählen
Montag haben sich alle gewundert warum
hat Georgia Meloni keine Pressekonferenz
gemacht das machen alle traditionellen
Parteien immer warum hat sie ihren
Leuten gesagt am Sonntag nach der
sonntagnach sie ihr sollt kein Karussell
machen genau aus dem Grund sie wählen
nicht erschrecken sie will Europa nicht
erschrecken sie wollte eine
Pressekonferenz nichts machen dass
irgendwie die Märkte beunruhigt das
denke ich aber das ist ziemlich der Euro
ja in den Keller gegangen natürlich aber
sie wollte eben nichts sie will nicht
beunruhigen genau wie Herr Brook gesagt
hat sie wird hundertprozentig eine Figur
für das Wirtschaftsministerium wählen
die eben
Vertrauen erweckt sie wird auch Salvini
glaube ich auf keinen Fall ins
Innenministerium lassen
ob die Konfrontation mit Europa mit
Brüssel trotzdem
kann es denn sein dass wirklich das was
jetzt viele befürchten die EU und zwei
Blöcke zerfällt es ist so wenn wir
schauen wer hat nicht ich mag es zu
sagen rechtspopulistisch gewählt in all
den Ländern dann ist es immer eine große
Mehrheit also hätten wir so gesehen gar
kein Problem wir haben ein Problem eines
Wachstums vielleicht kann können wir uns
da einigen von sehr rechten
nationalistischen zum deirassistischen
zum Teil was auch immer sie
bewirtschaften je nach
landbewirtschaften die ihre Sache wir
haben ein europäisches Problem von
diesen Kräften weil das sind nicht
Kräfte die dieses Europa voranbringen
wollen die dieses Europa nach außen zu
einer Kraft machen wollen das Problem
haben wir auch wenn wir jedes Mal wie in
der Schweiz sagen können die SVP 27%
außer sind so viel kann ich noch rechnen
72% nicht dafür ich kann sagen Affäre
Klasse wir müssen uns gar nicht
diskutieren ist alles in Ordnung eben
nicht Kräfte die so militant sind und
die sind militant die sind nicht einfach
kompromissler die machen schon dann
Kompromisse wenn es nicht anders geht da
bewirtschaften sie sogar den Kompromiss
aber sie sind unglaublich stark weil sie
so minidant sind Stimmungen schaffen und
die Chance dass sie stärker werden oder
dass sie ganz ganz
rechtswerten dass wir vielleicht dich
Waage zu sagen in der vielleicht erlebe
ich das nicht mehr in 10 15 Jahren einen
europäischen Faschismus einen neuen habe
das ist alles nicht auszuschließen das
heißt die Frage war ja nach ob Europa da
in Zweibrücken zerfällt was würde das
wenn es so käme ja also Spalt Spaltung
sich vertieft auf verschiedenen Ebenen
was würde das für Deutschland bedeuten
dass er nicht nur geografisch mittendrin
ist sondern als größtes und
wirtschaftlich mächtig Land Europa ja
auch quasi von dem ganzen von der ganzen
Funktion her für Ausgleich für
für Koordination sorgen muss Europa im
Gleichgewicht zu halten jedenfalls
erwarten das auch viele von Deutschland
also ich glaube in der Tat ist
Deutschland bedroht ist dadurch also
einmal durch ein Italien das
wirtschaftlich schwaches weil Italien ja
ein sehr wichtiges Landes es ist die
drittgrößte Volkswirtschaft der EU grün
ist eine gründernation der EU es ist mit
60 Millionen ein bevölkerungsstarkes
Land mit einer wichtigen
mittelständischen Wirtschaft einer
exzellenten Wirtschaft und wenn ein
solches Land ein Schönberg von 2,7
Billionen aufhäuft und rund 150 Prozent
seines Bruttoinlandsproduktes
da defizitär steht dann ist das
natürlich für die für Deutschland und
für den Euro schon auch ein erhebliches
Problem es geht seit 20 Jahren aber mit
steigender Tendenz und Draghi hatte das
mit seiner Reputation Mister Euro und
seinen Reformen neues Wettbewerbsrecht
in Italien versucht das Bildungswesen zu
reformieren versucht die Justiz im
Ansatz zu reformieren war auf einem
guten Weg aber das ist die Frage wird
der jetzt fortgesetzt und wenn nicht
dann ist es glaube ich für den Euro und
damit auch für Deutschland schon extrem
suboptimal das ist die finanzielle Seite
und die politische Seite da muss ich
sagen noch mal zu meiner ausgangskrise
zurückkommend für mich sind diese
Figuren wie Marin Le Pen und Meloni und
andere Symptome Symptome einer tiefen so
eine tiefen Krise der EU und ich glaube
dass wenn wir nicht was sie ja mal eben
gesagt haben die in Anführungszeichen
normalen Leute ins Boot holen und die
Probleme benennen die da sind wenn wir
das weiter nicht tun sondern das unter
den teppichkehren dann fliegt uns das um
die Ohren wenn ich hier in Berlin erlebe
das jüdische Mitbürger es kaum wagen
können durch Neukölln zu gehen und
Hebräisch zu sprechen geschweige denn
die Kipper zu tragen wenn ich miterlebe
dass jüdische Bürger ihre Schüler in
Kindergärten bringen müssen wo
Polizeischutz ist dann ist das ja nur
ein Indiz unter vielen dafür dass die
Integration das kommt natürlich von von
rechter deutscher Seite klar aber nicht
nur und das ist ein Dienst dafür dass
die Integration nicht ganz perfekt
gelungen ist um es extrem zurückhaltend
zu formulieren und da könnte man noch
eine Reihe weiterbeispielen wenn wir das
weiter tabuisieren wenn wir das weiter
tabuisieren und stattdessen sozusagen
minoritätenprobleme extrem in den Fokus
stellen aber die Kernprobleme extrem in
den Schatten dann werden die melonis
weiter zunehmen und das ist meine große
Sorge das ist wunderbar ausgeführt was
wirklich auf linker Seite auch in
Deutschland überhaupt noch interessiert
links grün interessiert sich für den
globalen Süden nicht für Neukölln und
die Situation in Neukölln der globalis
Süden ist das große neue Wunder Wort da
ist eine abkehrse interessieren sich
auch nicht wirklich um Europa sie
interessieren sich auch nicht wirklich
um die für diese Englisch angetreten
sind zur demokratischen linke gehört die
Arbeiterbewegung
das ist ihr das ist ihr Feld dort sind
sie überhaupt nicht mehr Sie
interessiert sie nicht sogar eine
gewisse Verachtung und Sie haben dafür
immer eine ökonomische Lösung sie sagen
ja wir machen das Bürgergeldes gut wir
machen ich weiß nicht wie das schaffen
Hartz IV machen etwas besseres aber das
Problem ist ein kulturelles wir haben
heute ein Kulturkampf und dieses Gefühl
gearbeitet Bewegung war mal eine
kulturelle Bewegung eine
Bildungsbewegung das ist übrigens auch
die CDU es meine Bitte sehr der
ortoliberalismus sogar hat diese Aspekt
hat diesen kulturellen Aspekt und das
fehlt das fehlt wird nur noch reduziert
auf der Druck müssen wir uns in
Deutschland da ganz warm anziehen wenn
wir mal die ganzen Nachbarschaft in der
Europäischen Union Ansehen von wenigen
Ausnahmen abgesehen Frankreich Spanien
Portugal meine ich jetzt als Ausnahme
Länder wie auch in Dänemark gibt es eine
starke rechte Partei Schweden es gibt
die Wahren Finnen die in Finnland auch
nicht gerade machtlos und es gibt Polen
es gibt Tschechien Slowakei alles nicht
sehr stabile politische Systeme auch
Parteiensysteme Ungarn kennen wir
Slowenien Kroatien von Rumänien und
Bulgarien gar nicht zu sprechen das
heißt ein Großteil unserer Freunde in
der Europäischen Union Leben in
politischen Verhältnissen die uns
eigentlich Angst machen müssen
ich glaube wir sind nicht besser
wir haben die AFD wir haben sagen
Wagenknecht und andere wir haben
bestimmte andere Probleme in unserem
Land ja ist es keine europäische
Spaltung wir haben diese Spaltung in
jedem einzelnen Land mehr oder weniger
stark und deswegen muss ich an Meyer
hier recht geben dies ist eine Frage
dass
Arbeitnehmer Mittelstand sich nicht
ernst genommen fühlen weder kulturell
noch was die soziale Frage angeht wenn
man jetzt in Berlin 3.500 Euro verdienen
muss als eine vierköpfige Familie um
dasselbe gilt zu haben wie derjenige des
Bürgergeld kriegt und wir gleich weiter
dann kommen sie genau zu diesem Punkt
nehmen die sie da sehen müssen was wir
tun müssen es wird ihm auf Europa
geschoben und die anderen wir haben das
Problem in allen demokratischen
Gesellschaften und deswegen müssen wir
dafür sorgen tragen wenn wir zu Europa
kommen dass die Identität einen einer
Nation und Europa nicht im Widerspruch
steht sondern ein Teil ist Helmut Kohl
hat gesagt die Pfalz ist meine Heimat
Deutschland ist mein Vaterland die
Europa ist meine Zukunft das gehört
alles zusammen wenn man Europa nur sagt
alles und dann machen wir
große kulturelle Geschichten und das
kennen dann wird europaweit beschlossen
kann es ja gar nicht beschließen aber
dieses Image entsteht ist das eine
Katastrophe wo die nicht mehr mitmachen
und dieser Begriff Heimat jemand hatte
sie erwähnt ist außerordenburg möchte
Heimat im Sinne von heimlich haben das
wurde hier in Deutschland von bestimmten
Leuten ja als rückständig und
kolonialistisch bezeichnet wenn ich
einige Diskussion sehe und das muss man
glaube ich mal meine größte Sorge habe
ich dass du Europa passieren kann das
handelt dies ist ein Kampf den wir in
allen nationalfladen machen müssen meine
größte Sorge ist wenn ich mir Berlusconi
und Salvini angucke und was Europa
angeht ist die Frage des Bestandes des
Rechtsstaates und der Unabhängigkeit der
Rechtsprechung das ist der einzige Punkt
vor dem ich Sorge haben dass die
orbansche und kaczynische Politik die
genau da angesetzt haben auch der
berlusconi hat schon vor 15 Jahren alle
Richter als Kommunisten bezeichnet die
Axt an das italienische
Verfassungsgefüge setzen nein sie kann
es nicht weil sie keine zwei Drittel
Mehrheit hat sie hat eine absolute
Mehrheit aber das ist genau der Punkt
ich glaube gerade weil sie keine
magischen hat
politische ökonomische Revolution zu
machen sie kann Pipi machen und sie hat
vor allen Dingen was sie nicht machen
kann und das ist auch der große
Unterschied zu der Finanzkrise und zu
Griechenland und warum ich glaube dass
diese Vergleiche etwas an den Haaren
gezogen sind wir sind in der umgekehrten
Situation wir kriegen Geld von Europa
massiv momentan
Italien was viele vergessen auch
Kommentatoren in diesen Tagen die ich
sehr in Zeitungen die unglaubliche
Sachen geschrieben haben so von wegen
die nehmen unser Geld und und dann und
dann abscheuen sie uns noch ich sehr
berühmter Kommentator hat gesagt und hat
schon wieder erzählt er hat schon wieder
so so geschrieben als wäre Italien kein
Nettozahler Italien war immer
Nettozahler in Europa und deswegen
müssen wir keinen anderen nettozahlers
Geld nehmen ja wir kriegen das Geld aus
einem Fond bitte in Deutschland
aber was ich sagen wollte genauso genau
weil sie da keinen Raum haben wird
Politik zu machen wird sie natürlich
woanders Politik machen müssen und ich
fürchte es wird da wird sie eben eine
Konvergenz mit Polen und Ungarn sogar
suchen ich meine Polen ist seit letzten
Herbst in einem institutionellen
Konflikt mit den europäischen
Institutionen das ist etwas was wir noch
nie gesehen haben und ich denke sie sind
die Experten aber wir riskieren sogar
das Polen aus aus Europa
herausgeschmissen mich was passiert wenn
ein Verfassungsgericht sagt unser Gesetz
steht höher als das europäische Gesetz
und Meloni hat das indirekt bedroht ich
bin fertig sie hat gesagt wir wollen
Souveränität zurücknehmen nach Italien
was bedeutet das das macht mich wirklich
was bedeutet dieser Befund für Europa
für die Europäische Union gerade in
einer Zeit in der der Zusammenhalt
besonders wichtig wäre der Überfall auf
die Ukraine die feindsinnige Haltung von
Russland wir wissen nicht was mit diesen
beiden Gaspipelines in der Ostsee heute
passiert ist mit diesen Druckabfall und
diesen Explosionen es folgt aus allen
wahrscheinlich eine große Inflation eine
Rezession in vielen europäischen Staaten
können wir uns eigentlich einen solchen
Zustand der Europäischen Union in dem
sie sich im Moment befindet überhaupt
also es insofern furchteinflößend weil
dieser Trend da ist
Donald Trump America first und jetzt
heißt es polent first oder anory first
oder Italy first so und das ist glaube
ich der ganz gefährliche Trend dass man
sagt komm EuGH for forgettet die
europäischen Spielregeln zweitrangig das
nationale Recht zählt und wenn es uns
passt das europäische aber nur wenn es
uns passt wir wollen das Geld aus
Brüssel aber wir wollen es nicht an die
Spielregeln halten und wenn natürlich
ein Land wie Italien ein solches Kaliber
von der Größe von dem Stimmrechtsanteil
in der EU da kann ja Orban nur von
Träumen
in diese Richtung geht die EU sozusagen
auf der rechts Ebene als zweitrangig zu
behandeln und sich selber nach vorne zu
schieben dann wird es brandgefährlich
für die EU das ist das ganz gut aus
Deutschland auch die in Deutschland gibt
sie auch Herr Burg völlig völlig richtig
und um noch mal ganz kurz auf den Punkt
zurückzukommen was können wir denn jetzt
dagegen machen dass ich nicht die
melonis und Le Pens und salvin ist immer
mehr vermehren ich glaube in der Tat
dass wir von einer Tabuisierung in der
EU wegkommen müssen von einer
Tabuisierung der Verhältnisse Stichwort
Heimat meine Heimat ist Essen ich bin
Essener in Essen spielen lieber lesische
Clans
eine fast so große Rolle wie in Berlin
das heißt Berlin Bremen Essen Celle in
Niedersachsen so ja ein Beispiel erkennt
nur als Beispiel indem die
Stadtverwaltung
gehen hin und ladenexperten ein die sie
aufklären sollen über die kulturellen
Besonderheiten dieser Neubürger in dem
Moment wo diese Experten es wagen den
Begriff glänzt zu benutzen oder Mafia
ist aus und von diese Terrorisierung
müssen 40 Sekunden
zurück das Wesentliche ist dass wir
wegkommen aus diesem neuen
Klassengesellschaft einer Elite die sehr
akademisch geprägt ist zu der wir alle
gehören und die Leute die zum Beispiel
ein Beruf gelernt haben wir haben eine
Klassengesellschaft eine Schicht die
eine kulturelle hegemonierung hat ich
gehört dazu meine Freunde Gehör dazu
aber das ist nicht die demokratieansicht
also Identität
auch eine nationale Identität innerhalb
Europas finden nicht als Widerspruch
sondern als Bestandteil desselben das
zweite ist dass der Arbeiten dass die
Arbeitnehmer sich wiederfinden
die werden zurzeit von keiner Partei in
Deutschland oder in vielen anderen
Ländern vertreten das sind in allen
Parteien Akademiker und Intellektuelle
und der dritte Punkt ist ich bin nicht
so ganz pessimistisch denn wie bei den
Krisen mit der Finanzkrise der
flüchtlingskrise am Ende des Tages wenn
die Leute wieder begreifen das Problem
kriegt man gelösten und gemeinsam mit
Europa und keiner Krieg des National das
Thema wird uns noch lange erhalten
bleiben ich bedanke mich bei
Ton ja mastuboni bei elmarbrook bei
Frank am Meier und bei Ralf Sina liebe
Zuschauer morgen in der Phönix Runde
Streit um den Gaspreis wie viel müssen
die Bürger Stämmen
weiteres und aktuelles in Felix der Tag
mit Mark Steinhäuser heute unter anderem
mit den Themen die scheinreferenten in
den russisch besetzten Gebieten der
Ostukraine bleiben Sie bei uns
[Musik]